let me ask each of you to introduce the
other ben would you like to introduce
anna sure so this is anna kasparian she
is first of all a big round of applause
for anna because this is a chamber of
commerce meetings
anna's quite famously a bernie sanders
supporters it takes a lot of guts to get
up in front of a business audience and
she really deserves a lot of credit for
that for sure she's the co-host of the
immensely popular young turks which is a
show you can find on youtube it's also a
podcast and it's available pretty much
everywhere and she is also the producer
of that show executive producer of that
show
thank you ben
anna your turn
all right um first of all thank you for
having me um it's a pleasure to be here
and everyone's been so hospitable and
incredibly polite and nice and i really
appreciate that
ben
i just found out
uh
based on what gene told me
in like suggested me to be a part of
this conversation and i really
appreciate that um you know ben is the
co-founder of uh the daily wire
incredibly incredibly well known uh
especially in the media space the new
media space specifically but he's
certainly made his rounds in traditional
media as well
and he has uh really popularized a lot
of conservative ideals conservative
beliefs that i think
were
getting a little played out by some of
the old guard of conservatism so um you
know ben is known for being sharp uh
being able to defend his
viewpoints without engaging in personal
attacks so looking forward to having
this conversation with ben and you know
sharing our ideas with one another and
you know with everyone here so thank you
for having me well we love civility so
thank you
[Applause]
so for those of you who looked at it you
know our topic is leading political
voices the next generation of leaders so
you're thought leaders within your
individual
within your generation a generation
that's much younger than mine
what would you like the people of your
generation to know moving forward anna
let's start with you
well i think that my generation is
certainly pretty passionate about
changing things certainly changing the
way that they work and live we're seeing
that play out currently with the
pandemic and the
labor shortage that's taking place and
i'd like them to know that we don't
really need to reinvent the wheel
we've seen strategies and solutions that
have worked in the past
this country has gone through many
terrible things in its history it's very
short history you know relative to other
countries and uh despite all those awful
things that have happened things like
the great depression for instance uh the
country was still able to pull through
and i i would suggest looking to history
at the solutions that worked
specifically a strong labor movement in
order to you know really rework the
power dynamic that we're seeing right
now in the workplace i think a lot of
the
reasoning for not going back to the jobs
that workers were previously working in
uh prior to the pandemic has to do with
the fact that hey you know we've been
staying home during the lockdown
now we realize that spending time with
our family having a little free time for
ourselves being able to go out doors and
do recreational things that's important
to us so they're reimagining what their
lives could be like if they take a
little bit of power back in the
workplace and i think that that's
definitely possible um they just got to
fight for it they got to organize they
got to work together and not get
distracted by manufactured culture wars
that we see play out in the media every
day and how about folks on your side so
i mean i think that for folks on my side
i sort of have the same message for for
everybody on all sides which is that
the world did not begin spinning when
you were born
and there's a great amount of wisdom
accumulated wisdom that has built up
over literally thousands of years in the
united states over hundreds of years
that is well worth going back to as a
source of both inspiration and
understanding of exactly why the system
is supposed to weigh and work in a
particular way and that requires a
certain understanding of human nature of
human beings as both capable of amazing
things but also as inherently flawed and
ambitious and why you need a
governmental system that is capable of
checking ambition with ambition checks
and balances subsidiarity the the belief
in in a federalist system that allows
for experimentation on a local level
without attempting to cram one size fits
all solutions on everybody from the
federal level but that begins with
reading history it does begin with
understanding some basic philosophies
about how the united states works
because if it feels like the country is
coming apart it really does feel like
that more and more every day that is
because i think that there is a failure
to agree on some of the central bases
for the country so we're either going to
have to clarify where the disagreements
are or we're going to be in serious
trouble as a country
i love the answers because it leads
directly into what i want to ask you
about next this is going to be the most
obvious statement i'm going to make
tonight the last 18 months have seen
significant turmoil not only with covid
but with our social our cultural
upheavals as we've seen
people you know
protesting some just horrible egregious
acts
as you noted the future of work how we
work all those things are out there for
discussion trust in institutions
and and trust or understanding as ben
said of literally the basis of our
society i saw a great quote i mean we've
had the 1619 project we've had the uh
the book called 1620 1776 commission all
of them designed to push back on that i
saw a great quote from a noted political
scientist who said america is not a lie
but a disappointment but a
disappointment because it is a hope
would you agree is that that's a good
description and would you also agree
that the us is
an exceptional country ben i'll start
with you i mean i obviously believe that
the united states is an exceptional
country i think that our history is
filled with moments of glory it's also
filled with some terrible tragedy and
some terrible evil uh there's no
question about any of that uh to suggest
that america is a disappointment is to
suggest that utopia is a real place uh
or that the the whenever you say
somebody's a disappointment you have to
say compared to what
what exactly are you shooting for
compared to the ideal of course
everybody's a disappointment saints are
disappointments compared to the ideal
but if what you're talking about is
america as a whole is somehow
disappointing compared to for example
what other countries around the world
stand for or what they have provided to
their citizens or what they have
provided to the globe then by no means
america a disappointment america is a
tremendous success story in fact it's
the greatest success story in world
history
[Applause]
so there are parts of that i agree with
uh some parts that i disagree with uh
for the most part i just want to note
that the idea of america is incredible
idea
i think that the country has failed to
live up to its ideals i think that there
are certain things that are transpiring
as we speak that
go unchecked you know we are supposed to
have a system of checks and balances but
i think more often than not we see a
system that is in fact rigged in favor
of the powerful i'll give you specific
examples
you know in the beginning of the
pandemic there were lawmakers in the
senate uh who engaged in
this minimalizing just completely
minimizing uh the severity of the
pandemic to the point where i actually
didn't think that covid was a serious
threat to me my health my family's
health in fact in february i went on a
cruise with my in-laws and had a great
time and didn't think that covid was
going to be an issue
then i find out of course a month later
everything starts shutting down
people i know get incredibly sick
and then news reports come out in regard
to members of the senate who had a
classified briefing closed-door briefing
on the severity of covet and immediately
turned around and started selling their
socks they started buying tech stocks
realizing that people are likely to work
home
so they might need to invest in
technology or companies that
offer technologies that make that
possible basically there's insider
trading happening within the senate and
i'm saying it out loud and i'm saying it
on a regular basis because that kind of
activity that type of behavior first of
all is illegal for the average american
should not be legal for members of the
senate uh the fact that we have
[Applause]
the fact that we have lawmakers who are
personally invested
in businesses that they're deciding
legislation on
is unacceptable so when you talk about
the lack of trust in our institutions i
understand that lack of trust and that
lack of trust has led to the situation
that we're experiencing today with kovid
where people don't believe in what the
cdc is telling them where people
question what journalists are reporting
about they just assume
because of the lies that have been told
because of the system being rigged
against them they just assume that
they're being lied to
and and now we find ourselves in this
difficult position where we're trying to
find solutions we're trying to come
together so we combat covet effectively
get people back to work so people can
thrive families can thrive but that's
incredibly difficult to do when people
don't trust in our institutions
so earlier this evening we had three of
us had some interesting conversations
about
the way that our culture's broken the
way that civility has broken down let me
give you a couple of numbers that are
actually pretty scary 15 of americans
have terminated a friendship over
political differences the reality is 53
of the rs have a democrat friend only 32
percent of democrats have a republican
friend um
granted a lot of that his report is
being related to former president trump
uh kevin drumm
who i don't know but as a liberal
journalist with mother jones said quote
if you hate culture wars blame liberals
he wrote that in washington monthly um
is it fair to blame more liberals for
the culture divide or is it one that
both sides have to take blame for i
think that both sides certainly engage
in manufactured culture wars and it's
frustrating to see it
full disclosure i myself
have engaged in it and i think
instead of being oblivious or delusional
about it um it's important to
acknowledge when you've made the
mistakes right and so the demonizing
doesn't help
at the end of the day we have to realize
that we're all americans we all want the
same thing fundamentally we are the same
we might have different solutions
different ideas demonizing the other
side doesn't help
to accomplish any solutions again we're
seeing that play out in real time as we
speak
i think that there's a market for the
division and that market is being
exploited by our media it's being
exploited by politicians um and i mean
facebook is in the news today i think
that facebook uh you know it makes money
based on engagement and people are
engaged in the
constant conflict
so it's important to be honest about
what the real threats in society are i
think it's important to focus on why it
is that you know certain industries
including the media
engage in this culture of division
and we ought to talk about how the
incentives are in the wrong place i mean
there are no incentives to engage in
you know friendly conversation or
friendly debate i hate that my chair
keeps you know and i'm short so i'm
trying to lock it into place i don't
know i hate turning my back to people um
here i'll just do this i'll sit on the
very edge um but you know
we got to be aware of why it is that
people engage in the divisive rhetoric
that they engage in there's a profit
motive behind it often times i see it
play out in the media it's really really
hard not to fall victim to it myself
right but
when i take a step back and i look at
where the country is right now it's
shameful
you know we don't see each other as
fellow americans we don't see each other
as even fellow colleagues or workers in
the workplace everyone has a political
identity and that's it and that's not
helpful i think the division in the
country is incredibly embarrassing
especially on a world stage and we've
got to be more cognizant of that as we
engage in political discussions
i certainly agree with an enormous
amount of what anna's saying about the
the nature of sort of the world that we
live in where people feel as though they
are going to be ostracized socially they
feel that they might be fired depending
on their political point of view uh they
feel as though if they make comments
openly and this is true for pretty much
everybody across the political aisle
actually with the exception of people
who consider themselves on the far left
according to a cato study basically
every political subgroup in the united
states feels uncomfortable speaking
openly about what they believe except if
you're on the far left because then you
get to find people's old tweets and do
that sort of stuff um but the the
you know i i i'm not going to pretend
that i think that the culture wars are
irrelevant i don't i think that many of
the culture wars are highly relevant and
and not just relevant i think that they
may be indicative of sort of where the
country is going because the way that
most people experience interactions with
the government uh particularly the
federal government or with politics
generally is not always based on tax
rates or the very minut internacion
debates that we have over 3.5 trillion
dollar bills that nobody knows what's in
and then everybody just votes before
they read the thing a lot of the way
that people engage in politics
and we can i'm sure we'll get into it
but the the i think that a lot of the
ways that socially there's been a pretty
strong push uh from the left over the
course of the last 10 years in
particular and it's driven a lot of
reactionary resentment on the part of
people who are on the right and i would
suggest that a lot of the the support
for president trump for example was
driven by precisely that it wasn't just
about his economic program which
differed from sort of the traditional
laissez-faire republican economic
program a lot of it was about the idea
that he was a culture warrior who was
going to punish enemies and and all of
this and so to pretend that the culture
war either doesn't exist or that people
are making it up in their imagination or
that they are overestimating the impact
of it on their life is to ignore
how people are being treated in the
spaces that they treat with every day on
facebook on twitter in the workplace i
mean one of the reasons that my family
and i left california is not just
because of the living standard although
florida is way better it is also because
you know we left a place where we felt
as though our children were going to be
socially ostracized for a place where we
feel our children are not going to be
socially ostracized and that's a big
thing yeah no i mean you actually
brought up a few issues that i agree
with
the number one issue is the constant
policing of people's past what they've
said in the past i think holding people
to
the current standards based on the
current culture
you know if you're looking at tweets for
instance from 2009
and you're judging that tweet based on
what the current culture or the current
standards are it's a little ridiculous
right so going around demonizing people
based on their past statements um it
shuts down a conversation that could be
had right a conversation about oh hey
look
society has actually progressed on this
and you know look at what was okay i
mean
you you have late night hosts who were
in blackface not too long ago right but
the
culture has changed i think that you
know society as a whole not everyone but
society as a whole has realized oh well
blackface has a pretty terrible history
and maybe it's not a good idea to dress
like that as like a cute little
halloween costume but beside the point
you know i don't think that the culture
wars are are fake i think the culture
wars are taking place the point that i'm
trying to make is that oftentimes
whatever the culture war is of that
moment it is manufactured as a
distraction a perfect example will be
you know critical race theory which is
not taught in elementary schools
critical race theory is a graduate level
uh curriculum and the fact that it's
turned into some weird like oh we need
to ban critical race theory in
elementary schools it's ridiculous and a
massive distraction that i think is
intentionally meant to be a distraction
from what people are really feeling
frustrated about the precariousness of
their lives of their work lives uh the
fact that people feel overworked that
they have no control over the work that
they're doing that they feel alienated
over the work that they're doing these
are very real issues and i think that
you know the fact that it's really
largely been ignored by both the press
and the very
political leaders who were elected to
represent them in the first place has
led to the anger that we're seeing
bubbling up both on the left and the
right ben i think you want to make
couple comments i mean this will be a
very quick note i mean i obviously
disagree with you about critical race
theory and whether it is taught in the
public schools critical race theory
which i studied in law school it started
off as a legal theory but it has an
element of praxis and practice that was
meant to be implemented which is why it
is taught in education schools as well
and why in elementary school yes a very
boiled down i mean ibrahmax kennedy is
is preaching a very boiled down version
of critical race theory and his book is
assigned in elementary schools and the
fact is that when you are having
elementary school students who are
having to check off boxes with regard to
their race and then explain to each
other whether they are historically
privileged or not in fourth or fifth
grade that's that's a very dumbed down
version of critical race there's sort of
a game that gets played with regard to
legal theories that end up being boiled
down intersectionality is another great
example of this kimberly crenshaw it's a
very intelligent law review article
about intersectionality and how you can
be a member of more than one minority
group and be discriminated against in a
variety of ways and then that is used as
the basis for a much broader move in
american political life and then as soon
as you point that out they say well
that's not intersectionality it's the
original law review article that's a bit
of no true scotsman games playing and so
i i object to that and look it is a
relevant issue when you have terry
mcauliffe who's running for governor of
virginia literally saying in open debate
that it should not be parents who are
making educational decisions for their
children it should be the people in
education i mean that that is a culture
war issue that i think is of key
importance to people who have kids right
well see i mean i think that that's part
of what leads to the lack of trust in
our institutions i mean yes as a parent
you get to make decisions about which
school you want your kid to go to if
you're uncomfortable with the public
school curriculum you can take a look at
private school options um if you don't
want that you can homeschool uh but who
gets to be the art i mean we're talking
about parents making those decisions who
gets to be the arbiter of you know which
parent gets to be the arbiter of what
gets taught in any particular public
school i i'm i'm not really buying that
they're learning about critical race
theory or even a boil down for i'm sure
i'm positive that you know elementary
schools are not learning about systemic
racism and even if they are even if it's
a boil down version of that learning
about systemic racism is important i
think that that's something that's an
issue in this country that gets ignored
or completely denied and i think that's
wrong i think that's what also leads to
the division that we're experiencing
that's that's going to be the major
cultural issue right because the fact is
that i as a parent believe that if
you're going to you think there's no
systemic racism i believe that it
depends on how he defines systemic
racism so if you're talking about legal
regimens of racism no
if you're talking about history has
after effects of course so i think
there's a real problem with semantic
overload and a lot of our political
conversations and when people say
systemic racism sometimes what they mean
by systemic racism is history has
consequences you can't have 150 years of
well 300 years of slavery followed by
jim crow and uh and that not have after
effect which of course is true and
sometimes what they mean is that every
inequality in american public life is
due to some systemic inequity that is
currently taking place in the united
states which i think is absolutely 100
false i mean we certainly see that
playing out in our criminal justice
system are you going to deny that or are
you going to say that let's say african
americans or latinos are just inherently
more
criminal or i'm not going to say either
of those things i'm going to say so why
are they over represented in our prisons
i mean especially when you consider this
maybe beyond the scope of our
conversation but the answer is because
not all groups commit crimes at the same
level
that has nothing to do with genetics
that has everything to do with
circumstances you guys hold their
thoughts on education because i do want
to get back to some of that too but let
me move on to something else we talked
about
we talked about the trust issue and
there's some very interesting surveys
out there on trust
gallup did a survey there's a drop
across the board and trust in all
institutions except law enforcement
which is very interesting
congress sorry for my friends there is
the lowest
media is down there almost as low as
congress
those that rank the highest or small
business in the military so this low
media rank is that fair or is that being
manufactured as part of a culture war uh
oh it's fair i mean it's entirely fair i
mean it's i think that
one of the things that we've seen for
both good and bad the the fragmentation
of media is a result of systemic
distrust in the media and that's existed
for a very long time and that's nothing
new uh and i think that it's completely
fair for people to look at the media i
know there are people on the left who
think that the media is too right-wing
right obviously we on the right think
that the media is far too left-wing um
but i think that that that sort of
distrust in media sources is very often
justified i think that we're requiring
more of people than we used to in the
past because once people have realized
that there's an inherently political
angle to help people cover the news now
we're asking them if you want a full
rounded diet you actually have to choose
it yourself right you have to cultivate
yourself to watch the young turks and
then watch my show and decide who you
agree with and where there's sort of a
common locus effect that's the fact and
everything else is the opinion that's
asking a lot of viewers where we didn't
used to ask very much viewers at all
right you just turn on the evening news
and buy whatever walter cronkite is
saying whether it's true or not um i
think most americans waking up to that
is a good thing
the systemic lack of trust in media has
some bad downstream effects sometimes
because when there are no gatekeepers
they're no gatekeepers so i like the
fact that they're no gatekeepers because
i think the gatekeepers were very often
biased but without gatekeepers sometimes
bad stuff gets through
yeah i mean i think that right now we're
experiencing
people existing in various filter
bubbles so
if you are for instance uh consuming
most of your news online if you like a
particular
brand of programming if you let's say
lean more conservative and you're
watching mostly conservative news
algorithms offer up more and more
conservative news and so when you get a
if you have preconceived notions and all
of a sudden you're hearing or reading
something that challenges those
preconceived notions you have a negative
reaction to it and you see that playing
out across the board i'll give you an
example i mean i have family members who
are constantly consuming news online
my mom's a good example right she's uh
you'd be surprised she's my mom because
she's on facebook she clicked on a link
to let's say the daily wire perfect
example well facebook is gonna be
offering up more daily wire type content
and then all of a sudden when she's
watching the young turks she'll be like
well you know i read on facebook or i
read on the daily wire whatever uh that
x y and z happened and you're wrong
right um that conversation doesn't
actually happen that often but i'm
giving you an example
i was hopeful there for a second right
so look there are all sorts of issues
with the media right i mean the the
media for the longest time completely
ignored the very real frustrations that
workers have been feeling in this
country i mean the federal reserve
released data indicating that nearly
half of americans can't even afford a
400 emergency at the same time you tune
into cnn cnbc msnbc i mean it doesn't
matter across the board they're like the
economy is doing great
uh you know we're seeing uh record
growth and what they're specifically
talking about is the stock market but
the stock market is disconnected from
the reality that the majority of workers
are experiencing so i think that that
type of stuff leads to
uh people feeling you know
distrustful toward the press at the same
time they exist in these filter bubbles
and have their preconceived notions it's
hard to challenge that so there's a lot
of different things happening at the
same time i don't blame people for not
being so trusting of the media one other
thing that i'll note is that
the incentives are always in the wrong
place
the kind of stories that i want to talk
about on the young turks and do talk
about on the young turks get no
attention they don't do well in terms of
the number of views i want to talk about
international news i want to talk about
what's happening in brazil i want to
talk about what's happening in ecuador
it'll get like maybe 40 000 views at
most you know it gets a lot of views
i don't know anna casparian destroys
this person or here's the latest cat
fight like i hate it it's garbage it's
garbage because it leads to people not
trusting the press but at the same time
the profits are there the money is there
and i think you see that play out across
the board whether you're talking about
cable news or online media
yeah and at the at the dinner table
we're having an interesting conversation
it's clearly a generational thing my
generation grew up watching walter
cronkite and uh huntling brinkley and
all these folks and one things that i
saw in your bio was that you got
interested in this field because of
barbara waters so
what happens now to the barbara walters
i mean where does news reporting go are
we gonna will the nightly news be a
thing of the past and are we simply
going to continue to retreat to those
mediums that that demonstrate that we
know everything already where's where is
this going to go now well let me just
note i i loved barbara walters on abc's
so i remember um as a kid you know like
getting super excited after tgif was
over because uh abc's 2020 would be on
and i i was like fascinated by the fact
that this woman was getting paid to talk
to these incredibly interesting people
from around the world
and i was just fascinated by the
conversations that's how i got
interested in journalism in the media
but
i just feel like the type of
conversations that she had or
just news about world events
they don't seem to attract the kind of
attention that they used to and it might
be because of an oversaturated market it
might be because conflict tends to sell
manufactured conflicts tend to sell
but it's
i wish we can get back to a place where
journalism
still really existed where there was
like ethical
standards that were
you know that reporters abided by
anchors abided by i wish there was a
clear distinction between opinion
and actual hard news journalism
you know this is what i talk about with
my journalism students whenever i have
the time to teach i always tell them i'm
like look there's a difference between
what i do which is
analysis opinion
and what you should be doing as an
investigative journalist for instance
you know going out there and actually
gathering the news talking to both sides
not equating both sides and acting as if
you know you're completely neutral
but making sure that you gather the
facts on the ground and report them as
they are it's really hard to find that
these days there's still great
journalism taking place
i wouldn't be able to do my analysis or
my job without that great journalism
taking place
but
these are the people who are oftentimes
not paid well
ignored um and don't get any of the
benefits that someone might in the media
if you engage in the conflict nonsense
can we go back ben and separate the fact
based from the opinion now or is it
going to be conflated for the
foreseeable future i mean i think the
truth is that that was a relatively
modern construct i mean if you go back
to the foundations of the republic the
people who were reporting were also
doing opinion and that was true all the
way through the beginning of the 20th
century it was really only with walter
lippman in the 1920s that you start
talking about objective standards in
journalism and there's a difference
between an objective standard that you
apply to how a story is reported and
being an objective reporter meaning you
have no politics at all and i think
frankly if you want to reinstall some
sort of institutional trust it would be
good for reporters to say here's who i
voted for and then here are also the
facts that i am reporting on because
otherwise it ends up being a gotcha
right i see how you're reporting that i
see what you're doing i know what you
really think about this story uh so
that's a major issue i think the other
big issue obviously i mentioned
gatekeepers before i'm very wary of the
reinstallation of institutional
gatekeepers because if you want to talk
about market incentives the big players
have all the incentives to ensure that
they are the ones who maintain their
access via the gates
and this is one of my great fears with
some sites that we've been very
successful with like facebook is that
reestablishing the idea that they're a
quote unquote trusted news sources and
those all coincidentally our legacy
media sources
means that everybody who's not a legacy
media source somebody who started up a
company in the last 10 years right we
opened our doors in 2015. we're not
legacy media and so we don't have that
legacy so now you're shutting out all
the players who are actually entering
the market so you actually mentioned
again just a little bit of a shift
because you got my attention earlier
you're both bored and raised in
california
you left you stayed but we had an
interesting conversation at the dinner
table that maybe your perspectives on
california aren't all that different ben
i know you said you you were afraid your
kids weren't going to be we're going to
have a difficult time because of their
political views so um are you sad you
that you left california or i have not
thought for one day about that decision
that was the it was
it was one of the best decisions that i
have ever made for my family uh we are
overjoyed florida is a wonderful state
uh basically you know because of my
orthodox jewish faith that means that i
had to move to a place that had some
significant jewish resources uh and so i
was looking for a place that had those
resources uh was in a red state
preferably with zero percent state
income tax and that narrowed it down to
basically dallas and florida and so we
ended up in florida uh it's wonderful
but i mean it wasn't just that it was
the it was really a lifestyle thing
because my wife for years was saying
yeah we're paying higher taxes but you
make a lot of money so you know that's
fine but the problem is you don't get
any of the public services back in
california so in our area which is a
fairly decent suburb you had just an
inundation of homelessness in the area
like my kids could not walk around the
neighborhood we'd open up our front gate
there'd be a person shooting heroin in
their foot literally in front of our
house or a person passed out on the
street
we had our business on ventura boulevard
we had to board up windows during the
during the george floyd you know some
protest summer riots uh the we we had
you know the there were there was a
homeless person who smashed the front
plate glass window of our establishment
when we left and we moved our main
business to nashville then my family and
a small core of the business moved to
florida when we left uh we thought that
we were going to lose probably half the
people working for us instead i think
over 90 percent of the people were like
you're going get us out of here
everybody wanted out there's a reason
people are leaving california well anna
uh you shared some concerns too in
california like pennsylvania uh lost
another congressional seat so their
population is not growing certainly not
at the same rate as
texas florida etc so share some of your
concerns because you talked a little bit
about it before sure um so
california is poorly
governed right now um you know i was
pretty
blunt and uh transparent about the fact
that i signed the petition to recall
gavin newsom so i sounded too we were on
exactly the same page
now unfortunately the individuals
running against him were worse than he
was or is
and so unfortunately when uh the ballot
showed up to my uh in my mailbox i ended
up voting against the recall
but i was hoping that there would be a
better candidate as a challenge him i
didn't like any of the candidates now
the reason why i've decided to stay in
california is because i love the state i
know what the state is capable of and i
would much rather stay and fight to make
the state better in any capacity that i
have
but with that said uh the issue i mean
the issues in california are endless uh
you have
corruption i mean literally a city
council member had his office raided by
the fbi because of the pay for play
scheme that he was engaged in you have
real estate developers running amok uh
you know you have this effort to build
public housing to alleviate some of the
homelessness but at the same time you
know you have the
lawmakers in the state having like
giving these sweetheart deals to
developers who are very clearly
inflating their prices and taking
forever to build said public housing so
there's all sorts of mismanagement i
disagree with the way that they're
handling the homelessness issue as well
although i think my solutions might be a
little different
i think that this idea of um you know
being incredibly laxed with camping
has been pretty disastrous
and has attracted
look
homelessness isn't just a california
issue it's an issue throughout the
country
but when other states are pretty strict
against encampments and california is
very relaxed what do you think that's
going to do it's going to attract
homelessness
in the state as well i want to provide
housing for everyone i consider it a
human right
but i think the way that the state is
doing it through a public-private
partnership has not worked out at all
thank you so let's move on to another
public policy issue one that's being
debated in washington right now uh
tax the rich is a very popular sentiment
it's also now a fashion statement i
guess which we which we've all seen um
so when president biden looks into the
microphone and says pay your fair share
what does that mean
it means that if you're one of the 55
corporations that literally paid
absolutely nothing in federal income
taxes uh in 2020
and in fact received 3.5 billion dollars
in tax refunds or rebates
or tax refunds i should say uh maybe you
should pay your fair share but here's
the thing if the tax code is written in
a way where corporations can legally
take advantage of loopholes and
incredibly low effective corporate tax
rates
they're going to do it
right so it's one thing to say pay your
fair share it's another thing to
actually write
a tax code that is a little more
equitable and ensures that everyone is
in fact paying their fair share ben
what's pay your fair share mean i mean
the the obvious answer would be a flat
tax but the the longer answer is that
the united states has one of the most
progressive income tax systems on planet
earth
most of the systems in for example
northern europe are far less progressive
the the top tax rate kicks in a lot
lower on the income scale because you
have to pay for the large-scale social
services the the people who are at the
top of the income bracket the united
states the top quintile essentially pays
all in that taxes in the united states
not some not most all and the reason for
that is because there are tax transfers
and the transfer of payments that are
inherent in public services do not
accrue to the people at the top of the
tax bracket they accrue to everybody
else who's receiving that sort of
funding when we talk about you know
higher taxes on corporations we do not
have one of the world's lowest corporate
tax rates we are somewhere in the middle
in looking at the oecd countries where
we're certainly not the lowest on the
totem pole in terms of our corporate tax
rate in fact you know right-wing sources
like the heritage foundation will say
that it is much friendlier to do
business in places like denmark or
sweden in many cases than it is to
business in the united states tax rate's
pretty high in denmark and sweden
the personal income tax rate is very
high in denmark and sweden the corporate
tax rate is basically near or on par
with that of the united states if we
were to raise our corporate tax rate the
way that president biden is talking
about we'd actually have a higher
corporate tax rate than china currently
does uh the the notion that corporations
ought to be paying tax at all in my view
is mistaken given the fact that the
income is immediately either reinvested
in the company or passed on to people
who immediately pay all of that tax by
the time the by the time you actually
receive your income in this country the
income has been taxed about seven
different ways right you're getting
taxed through the corporation then it's
passed on to your salary which is taxed
if you invest in the stock market and
then you sell your stock that is taxed
as capital gains tax when use i the
government taxes that as well so how
many times can you tax the same dollar
before people begin to disrespect
let me um
i'd like to respond to that though okay
go ahead because okay go ahead to argue
that the uh corporate tax rates in the
united states are too high or that you
know i mean first off let me just
touch on the comparison you gave
regarding uh taxes progressive taxes uh
in european countries versus the united
states i mean yes the taxes might be
higher in those european countries but
what do people living in those countries
get in return they get incredible child
care i mean listen uh the average
american family two income household
spends a whopping 22 percent
of their household income on child care
alone right so
when you're talking about european
countries that offer quality child care
that by the way that opens up the
opportunity for people to go to work
something that we should maybe think
about as we're dealing with this labor
shortage 64 000 women left the job force
in april alone not because they want to
but because they can't afford child care
everything in this country is privatized
everything has a for-profit model and
there's consequences that come along
with that including for the business
community that might want you know a
more robust social safety net uh program
or social safety net to ensure that
people
feel comfortable enough to go to work uh
but we don't have that here so yes
people might pay more in taxes including
those lower on the income scale but what
they get in return is far greater than
what people in this country have been
getting
the united states has spent since the
beginning of the war on poverty some 22
trillion dollars in the war on poverty
we spend an awful lot on social services
in this country on a per capita level in
fact it is very much on par with what
the european countries spend it's just
not spent particularly well uh when it
comes to things like child care a very
young elizabeth warren before she became
senator elizabeth warren specifically
wrote about universal child care and she
said that it actually was contributing
to what she called the two income track
in a book that she wrote in the early
2000s and what she talked about is the
fact that there are a lot of women who
for example may not want to work and
what you're actually doing is
incentivizing people to have to go to
work because you are now providing child
care as opposed to providing a
competitive advantage to for example
families where one parent is working i
agree with you by the way that you know
child care is a very difficult issue i
also agree that this is why we used to
have for example family structures that
were conducive to allowing people to
help out we had
we there there are many businesses that
do provide for some form of child care
we certainly have many businesses that
provide for some form of maternity or
paternity leave
the the european countries which
obviously have been used as a model by a
lot of folks on the left
between 1970 and 1993 they experienced
exorbitantly low
rates of growth and the reason for that
was because they radically overburdened
their social safety net systems it
created enormous social problems it
created enormous immigration problems
they had to scale a lot of those back
and why
why would it create immigration problems
it created immigration problems because
a lot of people were coming specifically
for the benefits yeah okay well yes that
would be that would be to my point which
is it creates more problems very often i
mean but i mean
sure i guess that's yes if i put a free
donut sign in my shop people will come
for them no but if you have if you have
a robust
if you have a society that actually
takes care of its workers right if you
have a society that makes your life a
lot easier people are going to want to
immigra it's part of the reason why
you know people wanted to come here
people are going to want to live in
countries that have both economic
opportunities the fastest immigration
they're the best
programs that again just make your i
mean we talk about freedom if you look
at the world freedom index okay we like
to think of the united states as the
freest country we're not the freest
country you look at that list we're
like pretty low down compared to a lot
of these nordic countries denmark is
top of that list so look denmark has a
mixed economy when we have these debates
about ooh socialism versus capitalism i
think that those debates are a little
ridiculous because every country is a
well not every country but most
countries are mixed economies right the
united states right
exactly now the
the issue with the united states is
there used to be a time when public
universities were free right you didn't
have to dig yourself into a massive hole
to get an education there was a time in
this country where there was universal
child care that was
cut down to the point where it's like no
longer in existence unless you're
desperate and have like no money and
need to take advantage of some programs
that are available in some states but my
point is like
we have an issue here where on one hand
you know we're experiencing a labor
shortage we want people to go back to
work on the other hand people literally
can't afford the child care necessary in
order to put their kids in a daycare put
their kids in child care and be able to
go to work without their entire pace
the biden bill removes many work
requirements for many of the payments
that are being made to people and it's
incentivizing people not to go to back
to work which is why we have 10 million
open jobs in the united states and
people not coming back that's not that
is not what that bill does in fact
that's not what that means are you
talking about the right uh the 3.5
trillion dollar right i'm talking about
the 3.5 trillion 3.5 trillion dollar
reconciliation income tax credit offers
universal pre-k
which opens up the opportunity for
mothers to go to work if they want to go
to work the 3.5 trillion dollar bill by
the way has all sorts of subsidies for
corporations which i don't really
understand why the business community
isn't salivating over that because
rather than just going full force with
public programs which i think would be
the right way to go it's offering all
sorts of subsidies
in these you know public-private
partnerships now the physical
infrastructure bill has a lot more
corporate giveaways which is why the you
know business community absolutely loves
it offers the chance to privatize public
infrastructure which is why the business
community absolutely loves it uh but at
the end of the day if we don't create a
society where americans can actually
have families and go to work then we're
gonna be in a lot of trouble so to go
back to your immigration point you made
a mention a moment ago of people
immigrating to the country for the
benefits that's right abjectly untrue
the fact is that the united states is
great immigration growth throughout the
beginning of the republic all the way up
through about 1930 was entirely driven
by people who are leaving places that
many cases had broader benefits places
like germany to come to the united
states where there was no social safety
net the fact is that the vast majority
of people who used to leave and come to
the united states were coming
specifically to build life knowing that
they really didn't have a lot of social
safety net now that's not an argument
that there shouldn't be some state and
local possibility for social safety net
but the notion that the way that you
build a successful country that is a
world power and is capable of not only
making sure that the citizens are taken
care of but essentially making sure that
the entire western world is taking care
of which we did throughout the cold war
the idea that you do that simply by
raising the number of social security
payments that you're making to people or
benefit payments that you're making to
people that this is the way that you
build that sort of economy is just
not borne out by impeachment we've had a
real far-ranging conversation yes ben
let me ask you another question
our organization is one that on a daily
basis supports whatever you want to call
it the free market system system of
economic choice it was disturbing to me
and i think to our organization when the
national education association uh looked
at a resolution i believe it passed one
of their committees that called
the free market system one of oppression
but didn't call out other
totalitarian regimes so what does it say
when our educators don't seem to believe
in the free market system well i mean
obviously i love this question so i i
will say that the the national education
association is a very far-left group and
so it's not a particular surprise that
they're characterizing uh freedom of the
market in in that particular way it also
goes back to the conversation we're
having earlier about what sort of
control parents should have over the
education of their own children there's
a reason i send my kids to private
school uh the the notion that that
capitalism is a system of unfreedom well
government largesse is a system of
freedom ignores the fact that somebody
actually has to pay the bills it also
ignores the fact that all growth not
some all growth that has ever happened
is a result of capitalism meaning it is
the result of free market transactions
in which people consent to services and
goods from other people in which people
innovate and make new products there's a
reason that we're not still riding
horses and buggies around and that is
because of innovation it's because of
incentive structures it's because people
get to keep the fruit of their own labor
and then use those fruits of their own
labor in order to invest in things the
the true growth in the american economy
was never just a question of dollars and
cents it was what you got for those
dollars and cents all of that is driven
by entrepreneurs who are willing to take
risk and when you disincentivize risk
you end up disincentivizing people from
taking those risks as we become a much
more wage-based society and that that
has happened for a large segment of the
population
that means that you are incentivizing
people to not take those risks and
countries that don't have people taking
those risks end up being countries that
economically stagnate
yeah
so
those are the ideas that actually funny
enough
have been repeated over and over again
in our education system the idea that
you know
children or students in this country are
taught that capitalism is evil is new to
me because i certainly did not get that
type of education uh quite the opposite
in fact uh you know freedom is an
interesting way of framing it because
the fact of the matter is if you are
financially stable if you are you know
in the top 10 percent of this country
for instance you probably feel
incredibly free you have options endless
options available to you you probably
have a nice nest egg you have a little
bit of that economic freedom but you
know there are two different things at
play number one
well when you look at what
is incentivized under capitalism it's
actually led to a lot of our own civil
liberties being violated for instance
data collection that takes place on a
regular basis without our own knowledge
by these uh social media companies by
these tech companies who make their
money not off of advertising for
instance they make the majority of their
money off of selling our personal
information to data brokers it's part of
the reason why there are infinite
websites right now
so-called data brokers that just
sell our personal information including
where we live what our phone number is
where we've worked um i don't really
feel very free when i'm terrified about
my own safety because there's a you know
company that's literally making money
off of selling my personal information
so there are certain uh incentives under
capitalism that actually do infringe
upon our civil liberties and our rights
so that that's one thing that i want to
know but the other thing i want to note
is how free do you feel if you're
on the precipice of financial ruin
if you can't afford uh paying for a
medical emergency that you're
experiencing what do you do when you
don't have health insurance which tens
of millions of americans right now don't
have because of the exorbitant prices
associated with it how free do you feel
if you're a wage worker who has not
experienced your real wages increase in
literally decades wages have not kept up
with inflation so how free do you feel
when you want to leave your job but you
can't
because your health care benefits are
tied to that work or tied to that job i
mean freedom again is an interesting way
of framing it because i would venture to
say that there's a significant portion
of the population in the united states
significant portion of workers in this
country that do not in fact feel free in
fact have experienced the precarious
nature of a capitalistic system that
forces them to work endlessly if they're
lucky in a full-time job if they're
unlucky in several part-time jobs that
they cobble together with no benefits
just to make ends meet let
me give you 30 seconds i was involved in
something with that i'll just say i
think that there's a bit of a
definitional game that that's very often
played with the word freedom freedom
obviously has two separate meanings
isaiah berlin talked extensively about
the difference between positive liberty
and negative liberty what you're talking
about are things that people need and
things that people want and that is not
the same thing as liberty i'm talking
about what people need people need
health care i i don't disagree that
people need health care but to
characterize that as a freedom is a very
different thing if the goal of the
government is to provide you the
opportunity to
seek
things right then then that is not the
same thing as the government providing
those things to you directly nor is it
the nor is it the same thing as the
government seizing that thing from one
person and giving it to you here to
prove to characterize it as freedom is a
real mischaracterization again i'm happy
to discuss whether or not we should
change the programming here but i think
that the the sleight of hand that's
played by equating freedom of speech for
example or freedom from being murdered
on the street uh or or freedom to to
dispose of your capital as you see fit
to to characterize that in the same
language they would use to discuss why
you need a house
that's that's it's it's a difference in
kind it's apples and oranges yeah so let
me just quickly okay guys
because uh you know this idea of taking
something from one person giving it to a
you know the redistribution issue which
i think oftentimes is uh framed
inaccurately you know when we talk about
redistribution of wealth i mean look at
the amount of money that gets invested
by our federal government in the form of
research and development whether we're
talking about pharmaceutical companies
or even companies like tesla the seed
money from tesla did not come from
private investors in fact the same year
that obama's administration invested in
the failed solyndra project they also
invested the same amount into tesla and
guess what tesla ended up being a
massive success the only downside to it
though is that now you have elon musk
who's whining and crying about having to
pay his fair share of taxes when during
the pandemic he became for a brief
period of time the richest man literally
in the world right so
we
i agree about subsidies by the way right
yeah so
welcome to libertarianism
so look but look those investments need
to be made that research and development
needs to take place because private
investors are not willing to take the
risks necessary
it's true that is fundamentally honest
the federal government's research and
development is what led to the internet
i mean it's a huge part of it the fact
that the government is a grab bag of
cash does mean that the government will
eventually invest in some things that
are worthwhile it would also invest in
an awful lot of
enormous piles of credit right the fact
is if you don't bear the risk of the
downside you're making a lot of bad
investments we've got a few more
questions and i want to get through and
we've got four and a half minutes so
anna you had said earlier comment about
education that people can choose to send
their kids elsewhere we are an
organization that firmly believes
in education choice and we've got a lot
of kids in this state and others that
are sentenced to underperforming schools
solely by virtue of their zip code
we tell families in this commonwealth
that's your school we would never tell
them that's your supermarket that's your
doctor that's your dentist you get to
choose
because and a lot of that to be blunt is
because of the collective bargaining
agreements with ten-year teachers and
how much you pay can we really get to
educational choices a lot of these
parents can't afford to send their kids
somewhere else can we really get to that
real education choice given the current
state of collective bargaining in this
commonwealth and in this country to a
large degree yeah absolutely i'm going
to say something that's incredibly
unpopular with this group and that's
totally fine
the best education in the world
currently takes place in finland they
have the top education model and
they have completely banned private
education i would do the same
okay so
first of all finland is not the united
states and there there's a frequent
attempt uh that it does happen a lot
where people will take something that
has worked in sweden or something has
worked in norway or something that's
worked in finland they'll say what if we
just take that import it here and it'll
work exactly the same way and it
typically does not work uh the fact is
that that finnish americans make more
money in the united states than they do
in finland for example they have longer
life expectancies in the united states
than they do in finland's truth swedish
americans it's true for north korea life
expectancy in finland is much higher
than the united states no you're correct
hold on
you're correct the life expectancy in
finland is longer than life expectancy
in the united states that's not what i
said i said the life expectancy for
finnish americans is longer in the
united states that is an apples to
apples comparison as opposed to
comparing completely different
populations and that's kind of my point
okay the fact is that the united states
has an incredibly diverse population and
that diverse population encompasses an
enormous number of people who have very
different beliefs about how education
ought to be done to suggest that any
national standard of education is going
to not only please all of those people
but prove to be successful in such a
wide variety of circumstances for some
330 million people we've tried this with
a gradually not gradually radically
increasing federal education budget over
the course of the last 30 years and what
we've got is failing public schools all
over the united states except in
specific local areas where there have
been attempts to take back control
locally i'd love to see more local more
localization and frankly i'm quite
pleased that if covett had one decent
effect it was more people taking their
kids out of the public schools okay i
want to
we got two minutes
and so on before i get in trouble so
let's let's go real quick um and this
might not be a quick one but
so we've we've had this discussion in
this country and a member of congress
has called for
and and many others have universal basic
income um
and her comment was we should institute
a basic universal income for those
unwilling to work would that be
supported in this country would that be
supported yeah um i think on a broad
level the answer is no although i think
that as time goes on and people become
more dependent on government then the
answer is probably getting closer to yes
should should it be supported in this
country the people who are unwilling to
work should be paid not to work
absolutely not i don't see why the
government should be incentivizing
people who don't want to work and have
no excuse not to work not to work
[Applause]
um
i mean look i this is an opinion i have
a different view of humanity and i think
most people want to live lives
with purpose
so i think most people do in fact want
to work i i mean for me universal basic
income is not the end-all be-all of
dealing with the economic issues that
people are having
i know that there's been a lot of focus
on that uh because of andrew yang and
his presidential run and his you know
demand that people get at least a
thousand dollars a month i don't think
that that's gonna solve the issues um i
think that we have deeper
problems that we need to deal with
and just throwing money at something in
the form of a universal basic income is
not going to solve that issue
but if we decide okay maybe we're going
to experiment with this on top of
providing a much more robust social
safety net uh then maybe we're having a
conversation but to me the issue of ubi
is is less
less interesting okay final question
we're almost out of time i'm gonna go
they can't go over too long because then
i get the hook
we've talked a lot about where we're
going and a lot of pessimism and a lot
of concerns
what gives you hope right now
what gives me hope is the
younger generation and just how fired up
they are about uh experimenting with
different solutions uh finally we have a
generation that's looking at what's
being done in other countries what's
working what isn't working
we're now seeing
more worker co-ops being developed in
fact there are as many as a thousand
worker co-ops in this country about 500
of them are in the startup phase
but that is exciting news because now
we're seeing companies being formed with
workers actually owning the means of
production we're not talking about you
know the federal government owning the
means of production we're talking about
actual workers making decisions
democratically within the workplace i
think that's the right way to go about
it i love that it's being experimented
with among uh younger workers and i
think that's the right way to go ben
what gives you hope uh what gives me
hope is the fact that because this is
such a diverse country and because what
we are actually watching in real time is
is one of the great sorting features
that we've seen in american public life
in quite a while right we're seeing
people like me move to florida we're
seeing people who are in blue states
want to stay in blue states and what
that's going to lead to is more
diversity in terms of the the
attempted policies
and that in turn i would hope would lead
to a couple of things one better
empirical evidence as to what works and
what doesn't and two i would really hope
that it would lead people to look at the
federal government and say this is just
something that cannot control the entire
country at once with one giant rubric of
rules we have to let california be
california and we have to let texas be
texas and we have to let florida be
florida and if we can't agree to do that
when we're going to be locked in a
never-ending battle for supremacy and
things are going to get very very very
ugly before this is over and i think
that the the great threat to the country
right now is the widely held belief that
the solution is not at the local level
and it's not at the state level that it
is all at the federal level and what we
ought to be arguing about each and every
day is how much money and what sort of
regulations we ought to pursue for 330
million people the longer that continues
the more we're going to decide we don't
actually want to be part of that body
politic that the rewards being part of
that body politic are not worth the risk
of people you oppose taking control of
that giant gun that is the government
and pointing it at you so i'm really
hoping that that some form of
subsidiarity is going to return uh and
that there will be some governmental
figures who are willing to sort of
re-establish the checks and balances uh
and and localism that were the hallmark
of the republic at the beginning and
should be the hallmark of it again look
i've enjoyed this conversation
please thank anna and ben for being with
us it certainly was a lot of fun
and thanks thanks to all of you for
coming out appreciate it thanks
good evening everyone this is alex
halper from the pa chamber i'd like to
welcome our online attendees to the
exclusive virtual speaker q a with ben
shapiro and anna kasparian just wrapped
up a an interesting robust passionate
discussion uh we're live here in hershey
pennsylvania known as the sweetest place
on earth i will say when we announced
our speakers for the dinner i think some
of our
guests questioned
whether that name would be put to the
test with this group but
uh i counted at least 10 times when the
word agree or in agreement was used
which i think is is encouraging uh you
also talked however anna about the
incentives that are built in that uh
almost encourage polarization
uh i know gene asked you at the end of
what gives you hope but uh talk about
how you see uh the trend in terms of
polarization in our country and and
where you think things are going
well i mean i wish i had a little more
hope in regard to the polarization but i
don't see it really getting any better i
can say that among
leftist circles certainly when it comes
to the issue of labor
there's a lot of talk about how listen
if you want to organize in the workplace
you got to understand that you're going
to come across
people who share certain economic
interests with you but might be
different culturally might be different
religiously might have you know some uh
characteristics or behaviors that you
might consider unsavory but at the end
of the day we're all workers and we need
to work together right those are the
kinds of conversations that give me a
little hope in regard to polarization
but those are happening on a very macro
micro level
on a macro level what we're seeing you
know on the you know
throughout the country is just more and
more of the divisiveness and you know i
really enjoyed the conversation with ben
today um you're actually
a lot better in person
to be honest than i expected and i think
that more of these conversations really
need to happen i'm happy that the um pa
chamber invited me um and was so
incredibly friendly and polite
considering how different my point of
view is that's a nice compliment it was
my strategy i said no i said i set the
bar super low
you know and then if i surpass the bar
about like that much
and that's that's that's where it lives
but no obviously it's an enjoyable
conversation when you get a chance to
actually address the issues and see
where where there's clarification and
where there's you know disagreement i
think that's just as important as where
there's agreement you know my i'm
friendly with dennis prager and one of
dennis's favorite phrases is that he
would prefer clarity to agreement i sort
of agree with that yeah so you know i
think it's important that there are
places where we agree and i think a lot
of that happens on sort of the
big issue level like we should be able
to have conversations there shouldn't be
bribery to corporations there shouldn't
be subsidies right like a lot of those
things we actually agree on i think when
it comes to the implementation then
obviously there are some pretty wide
points of differentiation and clarifying
those i think is is really important
because that does help get to solutions
i find that that clarity is is the
is
really a deep prerequisite for coming to
any sort of agreement and right now
politics is this this kind of ugly game
that's played where you pick big terms
and you argue over big terms without
defining the terms and so instead of
getting to some sort of solution you
just argue over the terms and it turns
out you're arguing right past each other
at least half the time
we got a great question um
beforehand about
historical context and ben you earlier
said you know the the world did not
start spinning when you were born and i
think both of you have talked about
history or students of history we feel
right now that that you know the country
has never been more polarized you know
politics is so dirty but we have times
yeah that's our history when things have
been bad we had an election in 1800 when
when the candidates couldn't say we have
meaner things about each other we
obviously have the civil war are we
truly in a uniquely polarized time or
does it just feel that way parapha
phrasing the question from the audience
first
well you know when i think about some of
the
scarier moments recently in in politics
like what happened on january 6th um
what kind of grounds me is the fact that
we've had some pretty terrible times yes
in our nation's capital in the past uh
there was uh notoriously
a kkk uh protest that took place in our
nation's capital um and so
it they didn't storm the capital but
still uh bombing in the senate building
in the 70s right that's true yes and
that's the other thing i mean i think
about it not just the senate building i
mean bombings were common occurrences in
the in the 1970s and so i know that
that's a weird way of looking at things
like wow things are really bad now but
they were also really bad in the 1970s
my point is that things can get better
right you look at some of the awful
things that have happened in history and
what i like to do is look at what the
solutions were to get past it but also
to help me ground myself when i'm kind
of in a moment of panic right to not
kind of lose it and try to um overreact
or over respond to some of the things
that i disagree with or some of the
things that might be a little terrifying
so i'll say that
on the one hand i'm optimistic because
of that because obviously we've had some
pretty horrific circumstances in
american history ranging from you know
the actual enslavement of a large
segment of the population to the
subjection of that same population to
the the evils of jim crow uh to the to
the the you know upright the unrest of
the 1960s and 1970s to the great
depression we've been through some
pretty rough times um but i will say
that a lot of those particular fights
were over
i would say much more significant issues
than the issues that we're having right
now i mean the civil war was fought over
the great
universal evil of slavery a lot of the
fights that we're having right now seem
to be over over issues that
in any sort of sane world would be i
think less telling like it's it's it's
kind of it's kind of amazing what people
are willing to go to war over right now
uh and i think that that does speak to a
lack of common purpose and common
principle uh there's a feeling for me
historically that since the end of the
soviet union uh one of the one of the
sort of areas that at least brought
americans together was at least we're
not the soviet union right we we have
our problems but at least we're not the
soviet union we can unite around that uh
and and when the soviet union went away
it turned into okay so what do we want
to be and there's some pretty wide
disagreement over what we want america
to be i think that there's a
trope in politics that actually isn't
true which is that all of us sort of
want the same endpoint we just have
different ways of getting there i don't
think that's really true i think many of
us have very different endpoints for
what we look for do we want a
redistributive society versus a society
that's more oriented toward you know
private rights do we want a society
that's more oriented toward free speech
or one that's more oriented toward
achieving proper public policy at the
expense of free speech these are really
serious battles so maybe the battles are
more serious than than you know they
seem on the surface
we got a question here uh for ana before
we get to that though just a question i
have anna you mentioned um
being invited by the chamber even though
policy differences no doubt um ben do
you get invited to speak to to groups
with whom you have strong policy
disagreements uh or other similar
experiences for you no that's that's
pretty rare um if i get invited to media
outlets uh even that is is somewhat rare
i mean there's
i will say that again i don't think that
the incentive structure is quite the
same there is a real career risk for
people on the left to have me on because
there's almost a secondary boycott that
then occurs for some people and i don't
blame them i mean they're i have friends
who are on the left and who will say
they can't have me on their show because
they're afraid of the blowback that will
then occur if they have me on the show
now i think that that blowback probably
won't materialize i think in many cases
it's just people who don't want to do it
because they just don't feel like it uh
or they overestimate how much blowback
it'll be or how tough it'll be um but
for some people it's it's very real and
it does exist i'm like
when i speak on college campuses i'm
typically invited by the in-house
conservative group on college campuses
it's typically not the administration
who's like we definitely need this
conservative to come in and talk to our
students
yeah i mean first let me just say you're
welcome on our show i appreciate it
anytime
yeah that would be a good conversation
um
yeah i mean i i can't think of a
left-wing equivalent of the u.s chamber
of commerce or the pa chamber of
commerce uh but i do think that opening
up these types of conversations is
important um so yeah there you have it i
appreciate that um question here from uh
chris mcgowan appears to be a captain in
the u.s army so uh captain mcgowan we we
appreciate your service a question
directly for
anna and i'll just read it out i was an
economist this is uh this is chris i was
an economist before joining the army and
my understanding is that progressives
don't want to socialize the economy but
just the public good sector of the
economy things like prisons police
health care military fire departments
that belong in the pro in the public
sector according to economists
um
am i correct chris is asking or do you
actually want to socialize the entire
economy
oh well
i i don't want to socialize the entire
economy um now
let me just note that i don't speak for
all socialists in fact there's a lot of
disagreement among socialists about uh
how
they would like society to appear so let
me just be clear about what i support
and what i would want i think there are
certain sectors of our economy that
should be decommodified uh including
healthcare education um you know i'm
pretty open about that on
the programming that i do
but in terms of uh markets
i i have a i i don't have a problem with
private companies i do have a problem
though with the uh power dynamic uh
among the
the way that i would classify it is you
know you have two classes you have the
capitalist class you have the working
class right and so the power dynamic is
just completely off right now where the
working class has no power um i'd like
to change that so that's why i'm so
excited to see uh the emergence of
worker co-ops within the united states i
think that's the right way to go
um the other way historically that uh
labor has found solutions in this
country is by organizing and forming
labor unions um and ensuring that you
know they had the power structure
necessary to do general strikes which uh
applied pressure to fdr and led to the
new deal i think that you know that's
what i was talking about regarding not
having to reinvent the wheel
um but
yeah i think that there are
opportunities for private companies that
i'm totally fine with but certain things
i do consider to be human rights
including health care including
education and there shouldn't be a
profit motive and by the way including
our justice system we shouldn't have
private prisons um i don't consider
private prisons i'm sorry prison's a
human right but i do think that you
should take the profit motive out of the
prison system because private prisons
have not worked out so well for society
so far
i mean so obviously i don't consider
profit mode of a dirty ward in fact i
think the profit motive is one of the
single greatest things that has ever
happened to humanity is when people
began to realize that that
innovation was going to create greater
wealth for them and for the people who
actually got their products this is one
of the things that has progressed
humanity just enormously since the
beginning of the 1800s the profit motive
is a wonderful wonderful thing it is not
it is not a negative thing now it
depends on what you're talking about
though um wasn't it wasn't a positive
thing in texas with their privatized
deregulated power grid
which led to 210 texans dying because
they didn't want to spend the money
necessary to weatherize their equipment
so there are certain areas where profit
motive is in fact a dirty word well so i
want to just clarify no i mean when the
state is involved with profit motive
then you have a real problem the state
paying for power for example or when you
have the state driving regulations
toward for example green energy and
subsidizing particularly less effective
forms of energy because they have an
incentive in order to do so that is not
paid off for by the risk they take that
also drives some really bad incentive
structures but profit motive is a
general rule listen i agree that there
are certain places where i'm not i'm not
particularly interested in profit being
the main driver of human activity
however the notion that that using
profit motive is sort of the all-purpose
it's a dirty word it's a bad thing and
and if there's a profit motive involved
this is what makes it bad as opposed to
bad administration or bad running of a
company they're good companies they're
bad companies it ain't the profit motive
that makes themselves profit motive is
universal to human behavior because
people prefer to see the receipts of
their labor when it comes to
unionization obviously we have wide
differences on on unionization uh i
think that the the law is
extraordinarily biased since the nlr ah
against
the the so-called capitalist class i
don't think the capitalist class exists
in opposition to the worker class i
don't think that my workers uh you know
the the people who work for my company
exist in opposition to me i think that i
you know
i i really don't know many people who
run businesses who are out to
quote unquote exploit their labor and
treat them like garbage i don't think
that that is something that they wake up
seeking to do i think that in fact what
the what private business has done is
drive competition for labor in ways that
non-private industry has never done
public companies are
public
publicly owned companies uh
particularly nationalized industries are
not famous for treating their workers
extraordinarily well the the notion that
private companies treat their workers
horrifically and that all labor is
exploitative except if you work for the
government which doesn't have any
incentive to treat you well at all
because you obviously can't do anything
it's the government uh is is i think
wrong i'm not opposed to unions so long
as they're not kneecapping people or so
long as they're not forcing anybody into
a labor arrangement they don't wish to
work under um but the notion that the
the labor arrangements ought to be
general on behalf of people who have not
voluntarily signed up for the labor
arrangement seems to be skewed yeah i
mean i'm just saying uh you know
in my opinion uh well let me just note
that
as an employer right it's not that you
you have to be awful to your employees
but
you have a fiduciary responsibility to
your shareholders to return
you know to provide a return on their
investment that's literally like it's
baked into the system that's true and so
as a result i mean what's the most
expensive uh cost within a business it's
always labor it's always labor so when
we talk about exploitation right
exploitation always makes it seem like
you're actively brutal and awful to your
employees which in some cases that does
happen but it doesn't even have to get
that far the whole point is to extract
as much labor for the lowest possible
price that can only happen in order to
increase profits and provide a return of
investment to your shareholders that's
just the way the system works that's
wrong it's an economic fallacy that
there's an impoverishment of workers
that goes on under a laissez-faire
capitalist system in which companies are
actually competing for a commodity labor
is a commodity when you have companies
that are competing for the same labor
the price of labor goes up this is one
of the great fallacies of marxist theory
is that there would be a general
impoverishment of workers that would
lead to the workers of the world rising
the fact is the living standards in
industrial countries have been rising
steadily into that living standards in
non-industrialized country
non-capitalist countries have been crap
for nearly all of human history wages
have been stagnant since the 1970s so
the argument that you know these
companies are competing for labor it's a
cute argument until you take a look at
the actual data what happens
what happens what happens between 1800
and 1970 and has the government grown
smaller or larger since 1970 well i mean
it's well it's interesting that you
bring up that time period because the
largest expansion of the middle class
happened following the new deal and the
new deal uh redistributed wealth and um
you know by the way certainly gave a lot
more power to the worker in the
workplace since that's been rolled back
since since the 1970s the notion that
the middle class has been destroyed as a
fallacy the middle class is largely
becoming the upper middle class nearly
50 of americans can't afford a 400
emergency i think it means me to
interrupt this discussion because it is
fascinating i know we started off by
saying i heard the word agree 10 times
but we brought you here specifically for
these discussions because you don't
always agree but uh so fascinating and i
just want to thank uh can i just say i i
really really love this because i love
getting into these debates and like i
get into these debates oftentimes with
my in-laws you know they're cuban from
florida and like my husband we always
end up fighting because he's like you
can't talk to my family members like
that i love that i get to do that it's
fine and there's like no hard feelings
so thank you i really like it
it has been a pleasure we want to thank
anika sperry and ben shapiro for joining
us here in hershey pennsylvania for the
pa chamber dinner thank you to our
online
attendees for joining us and i hope
everyone has a wonderful evening
[Applause]